what on earth does robert de niro have
to do with the ghostbusters and what's
with all the branded snacks ghostbusters
afterlife is an easter egg lover's dream
here are some of the best
we learned in afterlife that before he
died dr egon spangler lived in a
dilapidated old farmhouse in somerville
oklahoma the locals mockingly called him
the dirt farmer and he died deeply in
debt he also seems to have been obsessed
with revelation chapter 6 verse 12 as he
has excerpts and references to the bible
verse spray painted around the grounds
further tying the old friends together
when phoebe calls rey's stance you may
have noticed the former ghostbuster is
sporting a new tattoo on his arm the
tattoo on rey reads you guessed it
revelation chapter 6 verse 12.
in the king james bible that verse goes
like this and i beheld when he had
opened the sixth seal and lo there was a
great earthquake and the sun became
black a sack cloth of hair and the moon
became his blood in most movies this
could be called foreshadowing but if
there's such a thing as backward
shadowing this might qualify because the
verse clearly calls back to the day of
judgment on stance's mind in the
original ghostbusters film when peter
bankman told the mayor that new york was
headed towards a disaster of biblical
proportions what he means is old
testament mr mayor real wrath of god
type stuff fire and brimstone coming
down from the skies rivers and seas
boiling
fun fact in the original ghostbusters
there is a scene where rey recites the
bible verse to winston but he mistakenly
recites it as revelation chapter 7 verse
12 instead of chapter 6.
as we observe the home that egon died in
recently the dilapidated resident
screams a few things eccentric genius
ghost hunter and dude who lived alone
most significantly but like anyone of
retiree age there are lots of references
to his old job and an unwillingness to
let it go the equipment is most obvious
egon's grandkids find a ghost trap
buried in the floor a pke meter in the
main home and a proton pack and the old
ecto-1 vehicle also on the grounds
beyond that we see odd stacks of books
arranged similar to what the
ghostbusters found when they had their
first ghost encounter at new york city
public library no human being would
stack books like this
in egon's lab there are also numerous
references to his 80s nyc heyday to
enter for instance you have to slide
down a fireman's pole much like the one
rey once treasured under some lights we
see what looks to be the spores molds
and fungus collection that egon told
janine about and then we see a closet
filled with old ghostbusters uniforms
when the kids put on the uniforms we
know they scribble their own names where
the name tag typically goes when the
kids explore the pockets they also find
evidence that egon hasn't emptied them
in some time in addition to a pair of
his old glasses they find a nestle
crunchwrapper referencing a long
discussed product placement moment at
the beginning of the original
ghostbusters again i'm going to take
back some of the things i said about you
you've earned it
the kids later discover a very
old-looking twinkie in the glove box of
the ecto-1 this is undoubtedly a
reference to egon's big twinkie speech
from the original film it's not the same
twinkie it's unwrapped in the old movie
and we see egon take a bite but that's
an old twinkie
although after life concerns itself with
three generations and plenty of
characters certain matters of the heart
seem to be conveniently omitted while
others are only alluded to most
noticeable perhaps is the super sweet
egon janine relationship we all loved
from the original film it's reasonable
to assume that their relationship
fizzled out sometime in the early 90s as
the ghostbusters business did the same
it's also reasonable to assume that when
egon and janine began flirting with each
other his daughter callie was already
born so while none of this is canon one
could draw the conclusion that egon had
already been married and divorced before
the events of the original ghostbusters
film which provides some interesting new
shading to the character cali doesn't
discuss her mother and actress carrie
[ __ ] could reasonably pass for someone a
few years younger than her actual age of
40. could it be that in an afterlife
sequel janine would reveal that she is
cali's birth mother
probably not but if so remember that you
heard it here first
on much more firm footing the mid-credit
scene delightfully comes after the
credits lists to gorny weaver who had
not yet appeared in the film when the
screen lights up we see the alien series
star sitting at a table opposite bankman
playing the old psychic card game test
that peter once employed to hit on
college co-eds the pair seem extremely
playful and extremely comfortable with
each other it's a sort of movie
chemistry that only works when you put
two personalities together and they
click and it's a key element weaver and
murray brought to the first two
ghostbusters films it's also perhaps the
dynamic you might expect from an old
married couple although it isn't clearly
stated the scene would seem to indicate
that peter venkman eventually settled
down and put a ring on the cello
plucking finger of dana barrett now that
would have been a fun wedding reception
to attend
the name evo shandor might not mean much
to some heading into afterlife but by
the end of the film it will as briefly
discussed in the original ghostbusters
film chandor was a cultist who designed
the 550 central park west building that
eventually became ground zero for the
gozer invasion the architect's name was
evo shandor i found it in tobin's spirit
guide by employing certain materials in
the building's construction he made it
conducive to spectral inhabitation and
in the years since ivan reitman's films
shandor's backstory has been
significantly expanded upon by media
like 2009's ghostbusters the video game
references in afterlife begin with the
name of the new ground zero in
somerville in the first scene in the
film you can see egon's car crashing
through gates that read shandor mining
company established
an entrance that can be seen several
other times as well when the new
generation of ghostbusters begins
exploring the mine one of the things
they find down there is the corpse of
evo shandor played by jk simmons lying
in state in a glass coffin podcast finds
this endlessly creepy but even more so
when it becomes clear that shandor is
being resurrected alongside his beloved
gozer the gozerian
when it becomes apparent that phoebe and
trevor have some research to do on the
grandfather they never met in his old
life they go precisely where any modern
teenager would a card catalog at their
local library just kidding of course
it's youtube for starters teacher
seismologist mr gruberson shows them
clips of the so-called manhattan ghost
stories he explains to them when he
first sees the ghost trap later phoebe
goes on youtube again to watch the old
ghostbusters commercial while all that
footage is glimpsed in the 1984
ghostbusters movie the film cleverly
repurposes it as a historical artifact
this is particularly effective because
the climactic street scenes at the end
of the original ghostbusters effectively
captured the chaos of the gathering
crowd as well as a shot that feels
unplanned looking back now it seems like
news footage
the commercial meanwhile was
particularly funny because murray
aykroyd and ramus are acting like
inexperienced public speakers conveying
the awkward line readings and none too
subtle attempts to hit their marks that
you might have seen in an 80s low budget
commercial oh and the phone number in
that old commercial and afterlife bb
calls it and gets rey's stance
in one of the film's more random
comments when rey stance is running
through the events of the last 30 years
to catch up egon's granddaughter he
references a movie star as having
contributed to the downfall of the
ghostbusters when he drops the line you
can imagine robert de niro innocently
sitting in the theater getting all
offended and screaming at the screen you
talking about me
during the exposition dump stance
remarks that quote some actor bought up
most of tribeca and we lost the
firehouse this most certainly refers to
de niro who founded tribeca productions
in 1989 just when things would have
begun going south for the ghostbusters
with partner jane rosenthal together
they have since organized the annual
tribeca film festival and de niro also
opened the restaurant tribeca grill in
1990. the taxi driver legend has also at
various points at a stake in tribeca's
greenwich hotel the tribeca cinemas and
as of 2018 his business empire was worth
an estimated 1 billion dollars although
akroyd and de niro have never appeared
in a film together the line feels like
an ad-lib lovingly teasing deniro's good
fortune in business and how much that
firehouse property would likely be worth
today if the ghostbusters had held on to
it
gary gruberson goes to walmart scene as
a plethora of easter eggs and callbacks
many referencing the adventures of lewis
tully while the somewhat retired rick
moranis is pretty much the only
ghostbusters star to not come back for
afterlife the film essentially turns
paul rudd's character into a modern day
equivalent in walmart gruberson has a
normal scene in public turned into a
horrifying moment of isolation
reminiscent of tully's experience at the
tavern on the green first he spots tiny
marshmallow men coming to life the
so-called mini puffs adorable at first
and then turning into gremlins-like
creatures who take pleasure in turning
each other into s'mores then he stumbles
upon vin's clortho the demi-god tully
thought was a dog appropriately enough
with its head buried in a bag of dog
food like lewis tully gruberson is
cornered and transformed into the
keymaster another great touch is in the
scenes where gruberson is possessed and
rudd is undoubtedly running with the
same unmistakable gate that maranas
employed in the original film
as much fun as it is to watch the new
generation busting ghosts let's be
honest the film's money moment to seeing
the original four ghostbusters okay
three and a cg powered recreation of
harold ramus as a ghost once again
battling gozer the entire scene is
packed with references to the classic
showdown on the rooftop of 550 central
park west and some easter eggs are
easier to spot than others perhaps the
funniest is after rey tries once again
to make gozer vacate the premises by
identifying himself as a representative
of local law enforcement the gozerian
replies are you a god of course in the
original film rey answers no resulting
in the group nearly being killed by a
blast from its fingertips
ray
when someone asks you if you're a god
you say yes
and afterlife rey wisely looks to his
partners for help with the question
the final big easter eggs in afterlife
might be planting seeds to pay off in
other ghostbusters movies rather than
this one by the end of the film it
becomes clear that cali and the kids are
going to relocate to new york city and
continue their ghost-busting efforts
where it all began their efforts will be
funded by none other than winston
zettimore who the franchise seems to be
setting up as a bruce wayne-like
benefactor who will gladly throw an
endless amount of money behind
re-establishing the ghostbusters he says
i want to be an example of what's
possible i may be a businessman but i
will always be a ghostbuster we see
winston repurchasing the old firehouse
and even get a glimpse of the blinking
red light on the dusty old containment
unit worth noting the red status light
traditionally indicates that there's a
ghost in the unit good slimer being
there we'll have to wait and see
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]